[Musique]
moi ce sera bien
non pas parce que c'est le grand frère
on découvre ses benjamins
[Applaudissements]
hier par des hommes
ralentis et treize mois j'ai une
tradition dans cette émission quand il
s'agit d'amour de galoches de ce match
ne vient pas de galoches ici non
[Applaudissements]
et pas qu il ait déjà toulon vous mettra
des émotions qu'on va tout lâcher
isabelle a gagné pour son anniversaire
un smack langoureux seconde avec matthew
convient
dès mai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourrais-je pour fêter ces retrouvailles
de faire un petit smack
alors à toi ton tantôt là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
samba ce mois va c'est bon ouais bah ça
veut bien voilà
allez
[Applaudissements]
alors pas tu es vraiment des années